hi I'm Eric Voss and spider-man far from
home it's now giving us some first looks
at this movie and you know this is a
very raw footage hell this whole movies
pretty raw considering the title
character's current status is
technically dust I guess
so spoiler warning in case it's still a
little early for you okay let's dive it
in Swedish to explain everything that
you might have missed if you look
closely you can see what looks like a
standoff between two people Jake
Gyllenhaal as the villain Mysterio
notice how his costume appears to be
fairly accurate to the characters comic
book appearance of course - the fishbowl
style helmet Mysterio is Quentin Beck
he's a special-effects artist and
stuntman who works on Hollywood movies
he uses technology to create illusions
and hypnosis and smoke screens to mess
with people's heads net helmet protects
him from his own smoke screens the actor
has a beard here which to me suggests
that far from home will embrace Quentin
Beck's film production crew origin and
maybe make some kind of self commentary
on the way these movies actual
special-effects teams Wow would impress
us and blow our minds really were just
pawns in their own game and by having a
beard this is clearly a guy who's not
used to having his face on camera looks
like the kind of guy who might work on a
movie so far from home we'll take place
after Avengers for the way spider-man
homecoming took place after Civil War
and it's looking like Quentin Beck might
be another self-made criminal the way
Adrian Toomes was another guy using
scraps and tech that he assembled
himself but in this case to create
spectacles maybe even intentional
calamities so that he can swoop in to
fix the problem be the hero that saves
the day I mean just look how
over-the-top the costume is here there
are glowing purple lights that come from
within the suit it's kind of made with
these pieces of armor and that has this
billowing cape no capes it shouldn't
wear capes the MCU unless you're trying
to look stylish this suit is clearly
designed to be theatrical so would be
interesting it Beck intended that
theatricality to impress the populace in
a post avengers world maybe fill that
void with his own manufactured star
power now this would have just taking
place in some kind of carnival scene
that set in Prague Prague is one of the
European cities that far from home will
visit along with Venice and London now
the other figure in the footage is
spider-man but his suit is black here
some are saying this could be a nod to
spider-man noir from the spider-verse
but really I think it's more likely a
stealth version of his suit one of the
many
functions embedded in his regular suit
looking at other set images of this
black Sood you can see that he has a
belt a web shooter so this is probably
Peter Parker trying to draw a little
less attention with an alternate version
of the techy already has and then that
overhead footage also shows some black
government vehicles pulling up to this
scene with Mysterio I'm wondering if
those could be containing members of
shield we do know that Nick Fury and
Maria Hill are in this movie as well
maybe this stealth version of Peter
Parker's suit could be a function that
they gave him and he could be working as
like a contractor for shield while he
travels abroad now just a reminder
that's still looking likely that some
version of the sinister six could show
up in this movie in addition Gyllenhaal
is Mysterio Michael Keaton will be
returning as Adrian Toomes the vulture
and perhaps Michael mando as Mac Gargan
scorpion and pneumonic are as the
chameleons they're also rumors that
Hydra man could be confirmed to be one
of the villains in this movie and
possibly molten man at least based on
some toys that are being manufactured
for the film the comics multi man is
Mark Rexton an Oscorp scientist whose
body fuses with the molten alloy and
it's worth pointing out that mark Roxton
is later revealed as a stepbrother to
Liz Allen who in spider-man homecoming
was rewritten to be the daughter of
Adrian Toomes
anyway that family relationship could
just be one way multi-man could be
brought into this story comment down
below with your thoughts on all this
footage and follow me on twitter and
instagram @ EA vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for all the updates you need
to know from the marvel cinematic future
because someone has to survive Avengers
4
[Music]